this here in this man's voice every
single week and and I and I love Nesler
on the call on CBS it just is a guy that
I grew up listening to and I could not
be more thrilled that he's got a new
book out telling his story and all of
his great stories called play-by-play
calling the wildest games in sports from
SEC football to college basketball of
the Masters and more the author and goat
broadcaster Verne Lundquist back here in
the Rich Eisen show how you been Verne
rich I'm doing great it's been way too
long to hear you yeah it has been why'd
you write the book where did this come
from
well it came out of a basketball seminar
in New York about three years ago we had
finished our media session and it was
breaking up and there were four or five
guys who are writers who I was in the
midst of a circle of people and I
started telling stories which is what I
do for a living and they started
responding mostly they were laughing
thank God because these were intended to
be funny
and and one of the fellows said you know
what you've got a lot in your background
why don't you consider writing a book
and so that was really the genesis of
what is published being published today
they had to delay the publishing date
our pre-college did because they had a
problem with finding the book it's out
and and I let me be candid right up
front about this almost a year ago in
November of last year I had quite
serious back surgery in unveil at the
steadman clinic in Vail it became
complicated the recovery did and we were
I would say late February and I got a
call from HarperCollins and they said we
need manuscripts and we got nothing and
they they suggested and I concurred that
we had a hire a ghostwriter
so we employed a filament Gary brozac
who lives in
in Colorado and we would talk probably
four times a week and and these
conversations were recorded by call
center in Iowa they were transcribed
sent to Gary he would write a chapter
send it to me I fact check it approve it
back to him on to New York so he
deserves a lot of credit for the way the
words were put together I mean if my
thought that's right that's why you're
so great at what you did Vern is you
always you know don't make it about
yourself and you make others around you
look better and sound better and I'm
glad that you mentioned Gary who's uh
who's out there he's on the cover of the
book right here and so many great
stories again inside this book not many
people might know because obviously
they've known you for your national work
so much masters CBS and also SEC
football Olympics but you were the radio
voice for the Dallas Cowboys from
sixty-seven to 84 what's your best Tom
Landry story did you have my gosh yeah
well I'll share this one with you I over
the years I probably took 150 charter
flights with the Cowboys and the seating
arrangements for as long as I did that
coaching staff and front office in first
class
right behind the barrier media and then
behind us there was a curtain that was
placed with access obviously but that
was meant to give players a degree of
privacy so they could work it off win or
lose and we weren't to bother them and I
saw this from a distance almost every
flight we took Tom and his wife Alicia
sat in for C & D this is a brand of
flight with five first classic roads
they were in sandy and in equitably he
would be served first he would have one
glass of chardonnay he would get
never ever more than one he would get up
and again this is winter lose and go to
buy us to the very back of the plane
and work his way forward and not that he
stopped at every players aisle but he
had something to say to most of them as
he worked his way back to his seat he
would then sit down and I never do in my
life that Lully L'Amour
the the Western novelist had written
this many books Tom would pull out a
paperback and be immersed in that until
the plane landed back in Dallas I never
would have thought Tom Landry was a
white wine guy burn I would never I
would have never guessed that he was a
Chardonnay guy Tom Lee Chardonnay guy
I'm here to reveal things about
character there's a great line that I
use again in speeches Walt garrison
remains a good friend of mine he was the
cowboy pull backed up his nails and he
was asked once if he had ever seen Tom
Landry's smile and Walt said no but I've
only been here nine years Verne
Lundquist here on the Rich Eisen show
who's the biggest character you haven't
named the biggest character you ever
called games with or called games about
oh whoa easy and he's still on Fox with
would be Terry Bradshaw irrepressible we
had two years together they split us up
for two that we started working together
in 84 and we did 84 85 and for reasons
that have never ever been explained to
me we were separated in 86 7 I worked
with Pat Haden and different meal those
years and then Terry and I were put back
together 88 and 89 and he said to me
once and I totally agreed with it he was
so frustrated that he knew as long as
John Madden
we're sitting at Pat Summerall side he
was never going to be the number one
analyst he knew that and it really drove
him crazy so at in the spring of 1990
the two of us were sent to the NFL
owners meetings to represent CBS and he
told me then that he was going to ask
for a studio assignment and he wound up
going to studio and sat with Greg Gumbel
and in my estimation that's where he's
really shined he he's got all of these
gestures and then just stick you lations
and it come it comes across much easier
if you see it then if you just hear yeah
I mean Terry Bradshaw is like also one
of the greatest late-night talk guests
of all time Verne that you have so I
thought you'd go Raftery I mean what's
the gosh what's the while andrian
football right I mean Raftery right I
mean what's the longest dinner you ever
ride with Raftery the longest what
dinner 7:30 till 2:00 in the morning
he's an all lobbies guy right easy
season all-time great Oh God Billy Billy
remains one of my closest friends and I
look who I've ever worked I teased him
all the time that he's never met a last
call her to last call that he really
honored but rich he is so resilient and
and I must say this about him he despite
the the laughing reputation that and and
he tried to give it to me but I said no
the honors all yours
he arrives at game sight as well
prepared as any basketball or football
analyst with whom I've ever worked he
he's fastidious fast sidious in this
preparation well he's one of might also
be very fast it is
his enjoyment Diaz and he's one of my
he's one of my favorites last one for
you've earned because I know you have a
tour that you're doing here and that
you're kind of to have us part of what
was it like being at at at Augusta for
Jack or tiger in terms of the the crowd
noise which one yeah because because
Jack and I was at 17 when he took the
lead in 86 because that was a sustained
effort he began four shots off the lead
and and didn't make much of a move
through eight holes he birdied nine 10
and 11 the fellow who's now our
executive producer Dolph was in the back
of the truck doing he was putting taped
together not he was the guy who chose
the tapes and the olives this bland
sparrow he hollered at Frank in the
front of the truck
I've got Nicholas on tape with a birdie
at 9 and Frank turned around the Lance
he said you gotta learn how to tell a
story buddy
jessica's is not part of this story well
guess what
the crowd rich got just ignited and
especially Bernie 13 and then he go 15
and almost had a whole one at 16 so he
came to the 17th old Ballesteros had put
it in the water three groups of hind him
with and I've never heard golf fans and
guess the national members not ask for
your permission two years fans yes right
instead of instead of patrons yeah yeah
that's okay you're a lot back burn I'm
sure you'll be fine
oh good thank you you know I mean for
instantaneous yell yelling and and
reaction Tigers chip shot but for
sustained noise that the gallery on the
back nine of the Gesta almost thirty
years ago was just extraordinary
it is Verne you are to sir play-by-play
Verne Lundquist as you work
dimensional so written with Gary brozac
Vern I can't wait to read this I can't
wait for all of my listeners and viewers
to read it and I'd love to have more
time with you next time because I'd
listen you'd spin stories for an hour at
least rich I promise you I'll be
available and I always enjoy our
conversation right back at you that
means a ton to me that's Verne Lundquist
the Rich Eisen show weekdays at noon
eastern on audience